heated hookups romantic bombshells and
new couples I'm breaking down
Riverdale's sexiest episode yet on
Sweetwater secrets who pour me a
jalapeno margarita and get me a stand
because this episode of Riverdale was
h.o.t hot hey river babes i'm leanna
Galera and this is your Sweetwater
Secrets after-show for episode 2 14
chapter xxvii The Hills Have Eyes this
was by far the most jam-packed and
sexiest episode of the season and it
might be my favorite one of all time now
I'll be fangirling with you guys over
all the romance moments in 7 seconds in
heaven plus I've got exclusive answers
from Tony topaz herself Vanessa Morgan
about those shocking Shoni revelations
and as always I'll be breaking it down
my hisses and kisses of the episode but
first let's run through the biggest
headlines of the week in the blue and
gold breakdown first up the Riverdale
teens have a case of cabin fever because
Hiram Lodge conveniently planned a
weekend away for VAR Chi and bug head
welcomes what I humbly like to call
lunch lunch now I don't know about you
but when I was 16 my parents would never
let me stay in an empty cabin with my
boyfriend and encouraged me to take a
romantic getaway but then again my dad
wasn't a manipulative millionaire trying
to take over the town just as I was
getting all kinds of envious of the core
force couple retreat at Lodge Lodge
Riverdale delivered a delicious twist
furious after being denied entry to the
couple's only weekend Sherrill lived up
to her name and dropped a venomous
bombshell on Jughead and told him all
about that barchi kiss I just want to
make sure you know that our teen Betty
kissed in front of my house right before
Christmas like what tough serious that's
all enjoy your couples only we had to
kiss us to all right you know what they
say hell hath no fury like a blossom
scorned feel free to tremble now I'll be
diving headfirst into all the juicy
romance news in just a bit but for now
here's a little tease to keep you hooked
[Music]
I have to punish you oh yeah it's good
but what wasn't good was the fact that
Hiram decided to buy Sunnyside trailer
park and the Riverdale register and
cause a massive couple vs. couple fight
to top it all off the episode featured a
super scary moment when a cash crave
checkout clerk decided to rob the rich
teens playing house
screw you rich [ __ ] now just as the
greedy thief was running off with
Veronica's wallet and necklace
Archie chased after him but then stepped
aside to let Andre finish him off that
does it for all the cabin fever fun as
for everything that was going on back in
town well Josie filled Kevin in on their
parents clandestine love affair everyone
saw the movie love's Simon at the Biju's
because it's amazing and you should see
it too and Cheryl dropped a huge
romantic bombshell which leads us
straight into this week 7 seconds in
heaven wait sorry
someone jumping on the bed no that's the
sound of all the Riverdale sex going
down in this week's episode Veronica and
Archie kicked things off with some
horizontal fun but when Veronica thought
that Jughead was having trouble coping
with the barchi smooch she suggested
they cool off by heating things up
clothes off swimsuits on now he took
things further by suggesting a bit of a
boyfriend swap and Jughead was quick to
agree that this was a great idea Jughead
and I should kiss it's just stupid kiss
not to worry bug head fans
Betty quickly got the couple back on
shop with the return of dark Betty and
something tells me a Jughead really
enjoyed their first meeting back in town
we discovered some very big blossom news
now while talking with her new BFF Tony
Sheryl revealed that she was once in
love with a girl named Heather
but her mother tore their young love
apart she was the best friend in junior
high
she's to sleep over every weekend she
said I was deviant now you guys this was
such a gut-wrenching moment and such a
shocking revelation about Sheryl and now
it feels like the puzzle pieces are
finally coming together for her plus you
guys it's happening it's really
happening this is not a drill Shoni is
well on their way to becoming a couple
and I could not be more excited
in fact I called up Vanessa Morgan to
get the inside scoop on this potential
new romance take a little listen to our
phone call well you know Cheryl's
bisexual Tony's bisexual the fans have
already been rooting for you guys before
you even met one of the chances that
Shoni could actually be happening like I
think you can kind of Tony hi you know
Cheryl's a beautiful girl
probably some attraction and I think we
probably excited that she you know found
that out oh she's like me you know she
she loved she can fall over the first
people to and not to see some gender so
I think that really intrigued Tony so
what ends up being a friendship or more
I think that's really exciting for for
Tony you know Stephanie she can relate
to I just adore her and I'm so excited
for what's coming up with that couple
but now it's time to dive right into
this week's hisses and kisses all right
guys my first and biggest hiss goes to
Penelope blossom words cannot describe
how much I hate you woman I hope
you stub your toe and get a paper cut
every single day of your life hisses -
the fact that chick is taking creepy to
a whole new level stop staring at your
sister like that you weirdo
also who eats cereal like that I'm
keeping my fingers crossed that Jughead
kicks his butt he's creepy this is -
Archie for being fine with the fact that
Andre brutally killed a teen just for
stealing some cash don't get me wrong
stealing is very wrong but murder is
worse hisses - moose for toying with
Kevin's feelings and dangling his
relationship with midge right in front
of him what is wrong with you moose
Kevin is nice and his perfect cheekbones
and his hair always looks so soft just
love him he's a good-looking dude as for
kisses that kiss is going to the
Riverdale writers for giving us a
genuinely great episode that was filled
with romantic ups terrifying downs and
my new favorite character tipsy Betty
now kisses to Josie for telling Kevin
about their parents affair and it looks
like we're getting one step closer to
the cutest step-siblings of all time
kisses - some good old-fashioned girl
time and to be for keeping her besties
in check when v was batting her lashes a
little too much at that checkout clerk
okay kisses to Cole for crushing it in
this episode I loved all the hilarious
Jughead moments including this subtle
barchi diss while they were and jumping
on the bed is that everything if I ever
just have like a conversation and my
biggest kiss of the night ghost of the
fact that we had so much Cheryl in this
episode you guys we finally got to know
more about the emotional secrets that
Cheryl has been forced to hide and
that's all thanks to Tony for being
sweet enough to help Cheryl break down
these walls oh and by the way Vanessa
was very excited to hear that I was
channeling her once again in this week's
Sweetwater secrets here's a little
listen as to what she had to say what I
need to know from you vanessa is where
on earth is that cute Riverdale polo
that you were rocking when you first got
to Riverdale high because you know I'm
gonna be wearing my own on this week
Sweetwater Secrets
oh girl I'm out again uh-oh dressed in
the Riverdale Tolo I mean I need to
maybe uh steal one from order myself
because he's won that one episode in the
house of Jim return
I mean I'm planning some ranking
uniforms on it yeah that was one heck of
an episode and now I cannot wait to hear
your thoughts now you guys
what were your top kisses and kisses of
the week which characters stole the show
and which couple made you the most hot
and bothered share your thoughts with me
in the comments below or tweet me and as
always please give this video a like and
subscribe to e t--'s youtube channel so
you never miss an episode of Sweetwater
secrets or my endless stream of real
thoughts on these fictional characters
kisses to you river babes and I'll see
you next time bye
[Music]